over 100 million Americans are
experiencing some of the worst air
quality ever recorded as smoke from
wildfires in America's Top Hat makes its
way South the scenes from New York City
are downright Eerie a Broadway performer
walked off stage during a matinee
yesterday because she couldn't breathe
it is genuinely scary for people and you
know what that means means it's the
perfect opportunity for liberals to push
their fear-mongering climate change
agenda the smoke had just barely
appeared in the sky when Randy
Weingarten the nation's teacher Union
boss and Democrat Party operative but I
repeat myself she blamed the Smoke On
You Guessed It climate change Weingarten
tweeted climate change is real please be
careful today in NYC
but winegarden a well-known private jet
Enthusiast neglected to mention how the
wildfires in Canada are connected to
global warming or global cooling or
climate change or whatever and the
reason for that Omission one suspects is
that there is no discernible connection
at all
the wildfires in Canada have burned 9
million acres of land pretty bad
but is it historically bad
no
9 million acres is a lot
but nine million acres is nothing
compared to the 49 million Acres that
burned 20 years ago during the Russian
wildfires of 2003.
still 2003 relatively recent maybe that
was climate change too well what about
the 1987 black dragon fire also in China
which burned 18 million Acres twice the
Canadian burn that turned New York City
orange were the 1987 Chinese fires
caused by climate change
maybe I guess the lips have been
shrieking about some sort of
environmental catastrophe since the 70s
how about the Siberian wildfires of 1915
which burned a whopping 35 million acres
of land in Russia
was climate change already in full swing
by 1915
industrialization started in Russia in
the late 19th century
so
Maybe
would have had to act awful quick to
blame industry for that one how about
the black Thursday bushfires of 1851 in
Australia which burned 12 million Acres
33 percent more land than the amount
that has sent this historic plume to
America from Canada
how about the half million Acres that
burned every single year in Oregon and
Washington State alone since time
immemorial
prehistory
before a European ever set foot on that
land
were those climate change too
even a cursory glance at history shows
that lots of North America just like the
rest of the world has been regularly set
Ablaze long before any of the supposed
causes of climate change ever had any
effect or even existed
but a photograph and some liberal
demagogues with an agenda say that
wildfires are caused by your pickup
truck and your air conditioning
they're choosing to exploit a natural
crisis for their political purposes
they're confident enough that you were
never taught any of that history they're
confident because they control the
education system and the media
and the big Tech platforms on which
you're seeing all those scary pictures
I'm Michael knowlesis the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show you want to
talk about scary
group of Christians was escorted by
police away from a pride parade simply
for praying one man was arrested
actually we will talk to one of those
Christians who is Led Away by the
coppers uh it wasn't in some liberal
city either by the way it was right here
in Franklin Tennessee it's one of the
most conservative places in the country
we will speak to him a little bit later
if we can get him on the line first
though up in Canada
Canada not looking good man not looking
good forget about the natural disaster
that's going on what about the
ideological disaster what about the
political disaster you know the libs
especially on climate change they're
very very concerned about the imminent
death of all of humanity
sometime in a hypothetical future
but in the present they are actively
killing humans they're actively killing
humans through abortion Canada has one
of the most barbaric abortion regimes in
the country and they're actively killing
old people and the poor and the homeless
through with a euphemistically call maid
medical assistance in dying it's
assisted suicide they euphemistically
call it euthanasia means good death it's
the opposite of a good death and they're
doing it
at an alarming rate I I got this email
at this email from a nurse yesterday who
wishes to remain anonymous so I'll leave
her Anonymous but it gives a little
personal side to the statistics we're
seeing we saw last year some three
percent of Canadians died through
assisted suicide it's a shocking number
three percent of your country killing
itself
every year
or three percent of deaths rather three
percent and that was that number is way
up from the previous number of suicides
and it shows no sign of stopping
so this is what this nurse writes she
she writes quote I'm a nurse in Canada
my specialty is in wound care today I
had a patient who told me tomorrow he's
receiving maid that is euthanasia the
patient has all his mental faculties
happily married as far as I can tell and
is not currently in significant physical
discomfort I'm in shock my job is to
care for people physically emotionally
and spiritually I feel sick to my
stomach to see a patient who still has
so much opportunity to live life choose
euthanasia so much for euthanasia being
for rare cases we are flying down the
slippery slope of course
of course we are
when the libs tell us that euthanasia
quote unquote assisted suicide is just
about these Fringe cases of people who
are imminently going to die they're in
immense pain they're very very elderly
we just need to put them out of their
misery allow them that choice
that was never going to remain there it
was always going to become widespread
that's what happened in the Netherlands
the Netherlands now which has legalized
children killing themselves
legalize little kids killing themselves
the Netherlands where a woman who had
previously ascended to assisted suicide
was told by her doctor okay time for you
to die now and she said no I don't want
to not yet and the doctor forced her to
kill herself anyway and her family held
her down while she was resisting that
happened there too and by the way the
Dutch courts and the Hague even the
international criminal court said no
it's fine no big deal
doctor was totally within his rights to
do that of course this is spreading
because the principle is either that
life is good and you don't own yourself
and you're not allowed to do anything
that you want with your own body and
therefore we can pass laws against
suicide
and therefore you're going to get a much
lower suicide rate or the principle is
you can do whatever you want with your
own body and life is not necessarily
good and the only purpose of life is not
is not to seek God to seek virtue to
suffer in a way that is sanctifying and
edifying no the only purpose of life is
to get pleasure so whenever you feel
like you're not getting enough pleasure
you can just off yourself they're
principles okay and principles and ideas
have consequences
that's why transgenderism is spreading
like a wildfire transgenderism is
spreading like a wildfire because if we
establish the principle in society that
a man secretly can be a woman
if that's just what we all believe about
human nature then you're going to see a
lot more people falling into that
mistaken view of human nature
if we establish the principle that no
that's not the case and if you think
you're the opposite sex this something's
going a little bit wrong in your head
then you're going to see a lot less of
that now the big tech companies are
going to see a lot of what you're doing
online unless you're using a VPN like
expressvpn right now go to
expressvpn.com Knowles did you notice
the big tech companies today are
masquerading as privacy companies just
fix your privacy settings turn off app
tracking and you're all good yeah right
are we supposed to believe that the big
Tech wolf has now turned into our sweet
little Grandma I don't think so big Tech
feeds on your information by collecting
and selling off your data they can't
stop themselves from looking at what you
do online so to protect myself against
big Tech's prying eyes I have chosen to
use expressvpn
when you use the expressvpn app on your
computer or phone you were hiding your
unique IP address websites can't use
that address to find out your real
location or track what you do online
on top of that expressvpn encrypts and
rerats 100 of your online activity so
your internet provider Wi-Fi admin and
hackers can't see it
the best part though is how easy it is
to use I'm a lot eye not the biggest
Tech Guy you just click one button it'll
protect all your devices or boom click
it on your phone on your laptop you're
good to go one expressvpn subscription
covers up to five devices at the same
time so you can protect your whole
family too use the VPN that I trust go
to expressvpn.com Knowles get three
extra months for free
expresvpn.com Knowles expressvpn.com
Knowles to learn more
the worst air quality ever recorded in
New York City
if you look at the pictures it's it's
bright orange there it's weird it's
crazy and hazy the wildest reaction to
this came from some yuppies yesterday at
equinox
The Equinox is a fancy gem for rich
urbanites
and and the picture was taken and
published I think by the New York Times
but it was taken of this rooftop of some
building in New York
where amid all the haze the dangerous
air quality there are a bunch of wealthy
young New Yorkers
standing doing some kind of yoga
salutation standing up arms in the air
like a religious worship ceremony
which is exactly what yoga is if you
were an anthropologist you were an
historian and you came across this
picture
500 years into the future you would say
oh this is an example of religion in
2023 New York this is an example of the
kind of public worship
that that existed in Liberal America in
2023.
and a modern person right now would say
no that's not true they're just doing
yoga you don't understand man that but
the thing is the historian would be
right this is an example
of religious practice all these little
Millennial yogis who instead of going to
church they go to yoga and they go to
brunch that is a religious practice
they're they're risking something about
their physical health here
which is the air quality they're risking
that because of something more important
which is what it's the religion of
self-actualization it's the religion of
of being at one with the universe man
it's the religion of looking around and
seeing the big vast beautiful view from
the very very top of the tower it's the
religion of self the religion of do
whatever you want the religion of take a
moment and relax from your busy work
schedule it's
a religious practice yoga is an actual
Eastern
religious practice that's why there's so
much spirituality associated with it and
a lot of westerners pretend they can
divorce those things but you can't
whatever you do
a lot whatever you do habitually is
going to have some tie-in to religion
and in the case of yoga just happens to
be much more directly
spiritual
previously during a natural disaster or
some kind of Crisis you'd go in you'd
pray that's what Christians would do
you'd I don't know maybe you go to
church or something but that is that is
the church in New York and they're not
going to shut down
yoga Church during a natural crisis the
government might shut down your actual
Church they might shut down a synagogue
they might shut down maybe a mosque I
don't know if they would actually shut
down a mosque but they're not going to
shut down liberal Church
liberal Church being
the yoga studio and the brunch spot and
the pot dispensary they're never going
to shut those down now speaking of the
modern religious views the Air Force has
just joined the pride coalition
tweeted out June is pride month
the department of the Air Force proudly
recognizes and celebrates generations of
lgbtqi positive service members and
their contributions to the Air Force and
space force and the image is a
silhouette
of an Airman
saluting in front of the pride flag so
because it's a silhouette you don't know
which way he's facing if you look at his
art looks like it's his right arms it
looks like he's saluting out away from
the pride flag I suppose you could you
could also see it as the Airmen
saluting the pride flag either way it's
basically the same effect
the rainbow flag is our new Imperial
flag
the Star-Spangled Banner might be our
old national flag
but the liberal imperialists who don't
believe in borders who don't believe in
particular people who think that their
values are absolutely totally Universal
and they're going to spread them all
over the world they think it's the role
of the US military to spread these
liberal values all over the world
a lot of people probably the majority of
our ruling class that believes that
right now for them
the American flag is the rainbow they
have much more loyalty to the rainbow
they show the rainbow flag much more
respect than they would ever show to The
Star-Spangled Banner which many of them
openly protest
in sports in the NFL even in elected
office among Democrats that's the flag
flags are symbols that's why Flags
really matter that's why if you were
raised right you were taught that if the
flag ever touches the ground you got to
pick it up right away if the flag is
desecrated you've got to burn the flag
in a way that it's not like a Jane Fonda
kind of way not not in a hippie I hate
America kind of way but in a respectful
kind of way like a funeral pyre
because we treat symbols with the sort
of reverence that we want to treat the
thing that the symbol symbolizes
that's why they're symbols so what is
the American Flag symbolize the old one
the Star Spangled Banner that symbolizes
the 13 colonies that's what the stripes
are for
symbolizes the 50 states in the stars on
the blue background
and the red symbolizes what
Valor
hardiness
blood
the white what is the white symbolize
purity
in a sense
you'll notice I don't see a lot of white
on the rainbow flag I see a lot of I
don't see the white because we as a
culture no longer value Purity and
innocence and modesty and Chastity we
don't we don't value those things at all
in fact we mock those things we say
those things are evil and awful and
oppressive and stupid and prudish
so okay there goes that symbol what
about the red of the Valor and the
hardiness and the blood and the
sacrifice yeah that's gone too there's
red in the rainbow flag but it just
symbolizes all sorts of eccentricity and
variety and diversity for its own sake
what about the 50 states yeah that's
gone from the flag
the blue backdrop it's gone
the blue is supposed to represent
Justice perseverance vigilance yeah
that's gone no more Justice
just different flags different flags
mean different countries
me and Steve in different kinds of
countries a national Flag represents a
nation an imperial flag that rainbow
flag you can fly that anywhere you can
fly that in Europe you can fly that in
the East you can fly that in Kandahar
and that is what the Liberals in our
country want to do and do in fact the
pride ideology is spreading like
wildfire there was a story yesterday
Matt broke this story came from one of
our daily wire investigative producers
Greg Greg Ray
Nat had Craig producer Greg
go out and just see how easy it is
to be approved by the official serious
medical providers to have your testicles
removed okay and how long do you think
it would take I don't think anyone
should be allowed to do that save for
some medical emergency like testicular
cancer or something like that I don't
think you should be able to have an
elective surgery to remove your bullions
okay
at any timeline but at the very least
you say well maybe it should take a year
it should take a few years or a year of
counseling or
I don't know at least six months right
you know the real answer
22 minutes here is Greg speaking with
one of these medical agencies whose job
it is to approve or disapprove of male
testicle removal
you have a little bit of history with
your general dysphoria that may kind of
help me I want to I want to make this
letter as as
solid as possible to be like this
organic definitely need it I'll tell you
I'm happy to so when I was I was in
school and I actually wrote a big essay
um for admission to a club about how I
didn't feel like my biological sex
went along with how I felt and and I
told people that and they thought it was
ridiculous so because I thought I just I
just look like a guy so they like this
this is ridiculous
okay approved
so Greg comes up with
probably the most ridiculous story to
explain his supposed gender dysphoria
which is one time in school I wrote an
essay about how I'm a girl and people
made fun of me so can you chop my
golionioff
oh yeah sure that's fine here we go
here's the letter from plume health
which is one of these
sham medical providers which says
despite these interventions she
referring to Greg who went by Chelsea
Bussey that was his uh no known to plume
she reports significant ongoing gender
dysphoria she's seeking
orchiectomy I guess that's the I guess I
should stop using the Italian word the
Italian dialect word gullions and says
or orchiectomy
she has the capacity
to provide informed consent for this
procedure this procedure has been
defined as medically necessary by the
world professional association for
transgender Health wpath to treat gender
dysphoria wpath is a Bizarro
organization by the way we'll get into
them at some later date that's the
that's the real big trans activist
organization that is used as as credible
by medical providers so anyway 22
minutes Flume says okay you got it
there's another one of these scam
companies
folks f-o-l-x folk says right on the
website there insurance companies
usually require a medical diagnostic
code for gender dysphoria in order to
cover transition related charismatically
necessary you may not fit this
diagnostic code exactly but in some
cases the code is needed in order for
insurers to pay for the surgery a good
example of this might be a person might
be a letter for a person who identifies
as non-binary and does not have
dysphoria they might still need a gender
dysphoria diagnostic code attached in
order for insurance to cover the surgery
so folks here is laying it out in
totally plain English they're saying hey
give us some money and we will commit
insurance fraud with you give us some
money and we'll just lie and say that
you have gender dysphoria even though we
know that you don't you know that you
don't
regardless of what you even think about
gender dysphoria to begin with here you
go there it is
and a lot of people are calling this a
scam and it's kind of a scam in that
people are making money on it people are
cutting Corners breaking the rules
breaking the law getting some money on
people who are obviously having a rough
go of it
people who are scamming the system yeah
okay but it's not just a scam
it's larger than a scam it's part of a
new National sacred right
it's it's a it's a slightly dodgier way
to do something that is totally
enshrined in our law and our culture now
and being pushed by our liberal Elite
being pushed at schools around this
country being pushed at colleges being
pushed to workplaces being pushed all
over the place it's the it's the ritual
the right of
transition
which is just a further extension of the
ritual and the sacred Rite
in liberalism of coming out I remember
when I was in college there was a big
fancy ceremony on the quad for National
Coming Out day and it was a big rainbow
gate and you walked through the gate to
say I'm coming out I previously
adhered to a normal traditional sexual
ethic but now I'm coming out and I'm gay
or lesbian or bisexual or this sexual or
that sexual back in those days we didn't
have all 56 of them or 72 or whatever
we're at now but
that's that's a ritual
I'm Catholic
when I was a little baby I was baptized
that's a sacrament
with real spiritual effect I believe and
the operation of the Holy Spirit and
also an outward sign you put the baby
in the baptismal font and the priest
performs an exorcism and then puts some
put some water on the baby's head and
that's the ritual of it I was then uh I
received First Holy Communion again a
Sacrament that I
am quite confident has real spiritual
effect
real metaphysical working and also an
appearance and an outward sign that we
know this ritual by you get on your
knees you open your mouth you receive
the Holy Eucharist
I was confirmed in the Catholic church
that's when the bishop is at least
supposed to come shows up and gives you
a smack on the cheek and then you're
confirmed in the church these are
rituals
and as these rituals have ebbed away
from society
new rights and rituals have replaced
them
and today the the rituals of the coming
out the ritual of the transition those
are treated as much much much more
Sacred by our state by our ruling class
than any old Christian right or ritual
any old Jewish writer ritual any old
Muslim writer any old
anything having any even slight
connection to to traditional and True
Religion
now
one ritual that you probably don't like
to do is to replace your propane tank
which is why you gotta go check out
cinch right now go to cinch.com use code
Knowles picture the perfect Summer Night
the warm breeze on your face as you
Lounge in your favorite chair outside
the grill sizzling with Juicy delicious
burgers the aroma of the food is
irresistible
now imagine what this perfect summer
night would look like if you went to
turn on the grill and your propane tank
were empty
well that's where our friends at cinch
come in cinch is a propane grill tank
Home Delivery Service they deliver
propane grill tanks right to your door
cinch delivers on your schedule requires
no long-term commitment or subscription
plus delivery is completely contactless
you don't have to wait around at home
track the order on the Cinch app from
anywhere whether you're grilling steaks
or lighting up the patio heaters on a
cold night cinch's propane delivery
service ensures that you have the fuel
you need to make the most of every
moment go to cinch.com or download the
Cinch app to order new customers can get
their first tank exchange for just 10
bucks with promo code Knolls cinch.com
or download the Cinch app use promo code
Knowles to get your first tank exchange
for just 10 bucks it's a limited time
offer you must live within a cinched
service area to redeem it cinch.com
offer for details this weekend the
greatest interview show on the internet
many people are saying it's not my words
many people are saying it yes or no it
is back with a new episode featuring The
One and Only Charlie Kirk Charlie is of
course a very sharp and a very tall
young conservative Powerhouse we all
know them we all love him this is an
episode you are not going to want to
miss
my back and knee pain have greatly
improved by ignoring infomercials
[Music]
that's good news that you get to watch
shortly on the yes or no game we'll hear
some even better news the yes or no game
physical game for your home is back in
stock
remember we ordered a thousand copies
that sold out instantly and then you had
to pre-order then we ordered thousands
and thousands of more copies that sold
out very quickly then you've been
pre-ordering well now it's back in stock
you can go to dailywire.com shop to get
your game today don't miss out these go
very very fast if you already ordered
one it will be on its way soon what are
you waiting for order it now especially
because if it does sell out very quickly
at least you'll be first on the list for
the pre-order next time yes or no is the
best way to spice up your parties test
your knowledge of your friends and
family while discussing the most
titillating topics of our time some
people might call it cards for Humanity
you know some people might I don't know
who would say that the Le wire.com shop
order yes or no today
you remember we covered this on the show
some months ago
there was a woman in the UK who was
arrested for silently praying
outside of an abortion clinic on the
other side of the road by the way not
even directly outside she was on the
other side of the road and the cops came
up to her here's what they said
what are you here for today uh
physically I'm just standing here
what were here of all places I know you
don't live nearby Fitness is an abortion
or something keep praying I might be
praying
um so I'll ask you once more will you
voluntarily come with us now to the
police station for me to ask you some
questions about today and other days
where there are allegations that you've
broken come in space
if I've got a choice then
you're under arrest
protection order
they're so British about it which makes
it somehow even more chilling there's no
screaming yelling fighting it's just
what are you doing here yeah
I'm just here just standing here you
physically just stand in here
spiritually she's praying
but I'm just physically standing here
yeah are you gonna come down to the
police station with us then voluntarily
and if I have a choice no I'm not going
to do that we're all right then you're
under arrest
for praying
quietly silently in your own head
outside of an abortion clinic
and when that video came out we said
well at least that'll never happen in
America right
it's happening in in America there's a
pride parade
not in San Francisco not in New York
in Franklin Tennessee
just this past weekend
and there was a small group of
Christians who showed up
to pray
very quietly
just pray at the pride parade
and when it became clear that they were
praying not that they were screaming
not that they were yelling through a big
microphone about all sorts of things
with the pride people just quietly
praying
that was when the pride organizers had
had enough
spiritually they couldn't bear the
thought of Silent prayer quiet prayer
for them so they sicked the cops on them
and the cops escorted them away the cops
apparently even arrested one of these
guys
I'm being told that our connection is
too weak to speak with one of the people
who was escorted away maybe we'll try to
get him later on in the week
but luckily we we have some some clips
anyway here's what happened
praying at the Franklin Pride Festival
held at a public park until this group
which opposes the event was met by
officers and an event organizer asking
them to leave
[Music]
you may uh you feel free to exercise
your first member to rights but that
area is across the street over here
so we've heard multiple like
been watching and listening to the
conversation but we just need to make
sure that folks here comfortable safe
and so the event organizers have the
discretion to ask folks to leave the
footprints
officers escorting the group off the
premises Brian Sullivan and Jeremy
sladen say they came to pray for all at
the festival some of those words to God
also about what they believe is not a
family-friendly Festival we know that we
all messed up we all mix make mistakes
but when you start pushing things and
agreeing and accepting what's going on
then that becomes an issue so you see
this
a type of prayer here which is hey we
all make mistakes we all go through bad
stuff and so we're just going to pray
for everybody here okay that's great
pride organizer can't take that probably
the pride organizers would have
preferred if the Christian group were
out screaming yelling being really nasty
that that makes for a really nice clip
and then they can claim to be oppressed
and that they can have something to feel
righteous indignation about
what they can't bear is just the quiet
prayer
the quiet reminder of
moral and biological reality that's too
much and so the people praying quietly
get sent away
that's happening here
there is there is no room for contrary
forms of Prayer
in
the present United States we have an
established church with established
rights at the national level it's the
Church of Pride the queen of all vices
and it's got its rights and its rituals
and if you contradict that
the cops are coming for you
and they're coming for you even in your
red state
the answer to that is to vocally and
confidently defend religious truth
the answer to that is not to pretend
that religious neutrality there is no
such thing there never has been there
never can be there's no such thing as a
separation of church and state
we're either going to have one
conception of the good or we're gonna
have some other conception of the good
we're gonna have one set of rituals
we're gonna have another set of rituals
are Christians willing to to state
religious truth Christians joined by
religious Jews joined by religious
Muslims for that matter joined by normal
people who might be a little bit
agnostic and might not know exactly what
they think but they know that the old
way was better than the new way where
we're chopping off people's School
unions
are we going to State yeah actually
maybe the religion that built our whole
civilization that's the right one we're
going to follow that one
rather than the new religion of Pride
which which is
an even more zealously jealously
established religion than the one that
built our our country this is happening
Nationwide
you know Bud Light they pretend that
they learn their lesson transheiser Bush
they pretend that they okay we're sorry
well we're not exactly sorry but we're
going to back off the Dylan Mulvaney
stuff we're not going to push the trans
stuff too much hey come on we're just
gonna have commercials of horses and
cowboys now please buy our beer again
but then at the same time Bud Light is
currently sponsoring an all ages drag
event in Flagstaff Arizona
it's going to happen on June 17th this
was reported first by the Washington
Free Beacon
it was then
republished in the Washington examiner
it's it's happening
it's unclear how many drag queens will
be performing nine drag queens were
featured on the flyer
attendees who are minors are more than
welcome to come in if you're 15 years
old or older no but you can just walk
right in no problem at all
if you're under 15 you can still come in
you just need to be accompanied by a
parent or a guardian according to the
flyer so it's for it's for kids it's for
everybody that's transheiser Bush
totally unrepentant we've done a good
job really weakening them I mean they've
lost well over 20 billion in market cap
that's great news the only thing that's
going to work here those political
intervention because transheiser bush is
caught between a rock and a hard place
because transheiser bush has signed on
to all sorts of agreements that are
across corporations across Industries
across countries which say that they're
going to promote Pride as the new
established religion of liberalism
they're going to promote it
and so if they don't promote it if they
turn against it they're going to lose
access to social media platforms they're
going to lose access to other
advertising platforms they're going to
lose access to Capital because the asset
managers are pushing this stuff so what
is required here is not just
all of us together in a Grassroots way
stop stopping our consumption of
Bud Light and transistor Bush products
we need our elected officials to go in
and intervene and break up these Pride
cartels that are pushing garm you know
the the big
Pro
liberalism you know proliftism uh uh
organization that's now under the world
economic Forum Banner or ESG
environmental social governance policies
and all the rest of it we need the heavy
hand of the state to go in as our duly
elected representatives and break up
that Pride cartel
now speaking of the heavy-handed the
state
we got a new presidential candidate in
the race
and I know you're thinking of a bunch of
names oh is he talking about this new
presidential candidate or This I Promise
You
you're not thinking of the man that I'm
about to name
now it would be North Dakota governor
Doug burgum are you feeling the bergam
momentum are you take it away governor
I grew up in a tiny town in North Dakota
woke was what you did at 5am to start
the day
[Music]
a place where neighbors rally around you
my mom
was our Rock our hero
I started a shoe shine business
worked at the grain elevator
and has a chimney sweep
paid my way through college then earned
an MBA from Stanford
[Music]
I ignored those who said North Dakota
was too small too cold and too remote to
build a world-class software company
in North Dakota something about
I grew up in I had a software company
um
what
what are you going to do if you're
president
America's facing new challenges and how
we respond will Define our future
[Music]
you do leadership for our changing
economy
Innovation over regulation
instead of shutting down American Oil
and Gas we should unleash energy
production and start selling energy to
our allies instead of buying it from our
enemies
high taxes red tape and inflation are
choking every American
as Governor we cut red tape and took
North Dakota from billions in the hole
to a surplus
we balance the budget every year and we
did it all while passing the largest tax
cuts in North Dakota history a smart guy
who's achieved a lot
Doug burgum for president
a new leader for a changing economy
he seems like a nice guy so I don't want
to be too harsh about this campaign ad
and this I mean I already fell asleep
during it so I guess I'm being a little
bit harsh
this ain't it
whatever it is right now this ad and
candidacy ain't it and you see it right
there at the very end Doug Bergen New
leadership for a changing economy
economy
are we
an economy with a nation attached to it
or are we a nation with an economy
do we exist here in America
so that we can serve the economy
and markets and GDP or do we have
prosperity and GDP and markets and
everything to serve us the American
people is the nation more than just the
economy yeah for the 90s for a lot of
the 2000s we were told that
the whole point of government is just so
that we can make a little bit more money
that the nation is nothing more than
that people who happen to be living next
to one another so that we can all just
make more money separately but you know
I guess we'll have we'll have to have
some bare minimum regulations so that we
can continue to exist in physical
proximity to one another but all we are
really here to do is worship at the
altar of the free market and that has
led to Absolute chaos such that now
between America and our neighbor up in
up in the north which is giving us
plumes of smoke right now and is a
crystal ball into America's future we
are killing babies
we're killing our children we're killing
our elderly we're killing our poor we're
killing our homeless because they're not
productive they're kind of inconvenient
they're not going to serve the economy
we are chopping off people's genitals
we're creating a generation of eunuchs
and uh well frankly one of the reasons
we're doing it is so that scam companies
like folks and plume can make some money
so the big Pharma can make some money so
that even the whole system will create
more perfect consumers who don't who
don't worry about these extra things
like family and raising children and all
sorts of non-economic considerations but
they just exist out there to keep on
working good little worker bees who
aren't going to have to worry about any
of those things we've destroyed the
family we've destroyed our borders in
part so that we can import more workers
and make more money you heard that
I don't know just this strict focus on
the economy hasn't served us well it
hasn't even served our economy which is
on the brink of collapse
now we've got a more plausible candidate
who's just entered the race
we don't have time I I fear to totally
get to maybe we do maybe we've got a
little bit of time tip we'll we'll fly
through these candidates
and then get to one last important story
first though
you might have been one of the tens of
millions of people who watch Netflix's
hit show making a murderer if so then
you're going to love daily wire plus
this new exclusive 10-part docu series
with Candace Owens convicting a murderer
coming this summer whether it's exposing
BLM or certain fallacies in the
healthcare industry regarding covid
Candace Owens has never been afraid to
challenge The Narrative she will find
the truth wherever it leads when Candace
finds out that key facts might have been
omitted in Netflix's series well she's
going to set out to discover the real
story behind the notorious Stephen Avery
case and the end result is convicting a
murderer you will not want to miss it
right now there's never been a better
time to become a daily wire plus member
sign up now for convicting a murderer
you will receive an early bird discount
of 25 off your daily wire Plus
Membership you will also get all of the
other premium content from daily wire
plus including the greatest lie ever
sold what is a woman and the largest
collection of content from Dr Jordan B
Peterson join at dailywire.com subscribe
become a member and see the truth when
it finally comes out my favorite comment
yesterday is from Valerie Vaughn
Valerie who says someone needs to tell
Michael that his mayor Pete impression
sounds more like Kermit does it really
do you really think so you think maybe
someday we'll find it the Rainbow
Connection huh the lovers the dreamers
and me and by the dreamers I of course
mean 40 year old Venezuelan immigrants
yeah that doesn't ever occurred to me
but I guess maybe it does
the Buddha judge obviously wants to be
president
he's running that Shadow race against
Kamala Harris right now in case Joe
Biden takes a nasty fall Gavin Newsom
too wants to be president on the
Republican side we have yet another
Republican candidate who's officially
announced that would be former vice
president Mike Pence it'd be easy to
stay on the sidelines but that's not how
I was raised that's why today before God
and my family
I'm announcing I'm running for president
of the United States we can bring this
country back we can defend our nation
and secure our border we can Revive Our
economy and put our nation back on a
path to a balanced budget defend our
liberties and give America A New
Beginning for life
President Reagan described us as a
shining City on the hill and above all
he called on Americans to renew optimism
and believe in themselves again to
believe in each other every time our
nation has produced leadership that has
called upon this country to do hard
things the American people have always
risen to the challenge and we will again
okay
okay I got the message
this is a really great
2012 campaign launch
it's a really great 2012 campaign launch
but we are facing a regime level crisis
right now
and so
Mike Pence who
I really like personal a seems like a
really really great guy
the we're going to make America stronger
and our best days lie ahead and we're
we're really going to be optimistic now
and restore confidence in America I
believe in America it just doesn't
resonate we all want to be hopeful but
we don't want to be optimistic optimism
and pessimism are two sides of the same
coin they're just feelings that you you
pretend to have through sheer tyranny of
will hope is a fact it's a it's a
theological virtue and it's a fact
grounded in reality
if we're going to be hopeful that's got
to be grounded in fact and
and to be grounded in fact is to
recognize that we we no longer believe
in our institutions of government
neither side trusts the elections
anymore neither side trusts the other
one to have a a sensible understanding
of the common good we don't even really
speak the same language anymore we don't
have borders
we don't have a functioning economy so
you got to fix those problems first it's
a regime level crisis something about
the the way that the government itself
is structured and operates is not
working
that's why
for
all of modern American history certainly
in the 20th century into
up to 2016 you had candidates who were
just running on these Rosie well
America's Best Days lie ahead I believe
in them we have morning in America both
sides of the political aisle said that
2016 something changed Trump came out
and he said man this country sucks right
now this is in really terrible shape
these people these Libs have completely
destroyed our country this we got to fix
it we got to make it great again but
right now it's terrible
and a lot of people say there's no way
he's going to win that's a negative
message but that resonated for people
because the country is is in crisis so
Pence
very nice guy
but if he doesn't if he doesn't change
the campaign note he's going to be he's
going to be fighting yesterday's battles
10 years ago battles so now we're all
just waiting on Chris Christie
the criticons
croissants for short
uh I've told you I'm not even just
joking about it I think Chris Christie
could have a moment in the race I want
to put a little bit of money not a lot
of money but a little bit of money on it
on the predicted markets they're not
even showing Chris Christie yet on the
betting markets for the presidential
race so okay we gotta wait we will await
the chrysosons
we're in an extremely cultural battle
right now
and we're getting some wins on it too
Oklahoma just approved the nation's
first ever religious Charter School
there's a tight vote one vote determined
how how it would turn out a 3-2 vote the
Oklahoma Statewide virtual charter
school board approved Saint Isidore of
Seville Catholic virtual school so it's
not a physical charter school it's an
online charter school it's funded by
taxpayers run by the Catholic
Archdiocese of Oklahoma City on Monday
Saint Isidore named after the patron
saint of the internet will include
religious which is
that's a topic for another time whether
there is a patron saint of the internet
or what it means to be a patron saint of
the internet but anyway that's the idea
with the school
it includes religious instruction and it
has a mission to quote educate the
entire child's Soul heart intellect and
body set to begin late next year the
school offer online classes to run 500
students K through 12 and receive an
estimated 23.3 million dollars in state
funding for its first five years great
stuff
great stuff is it recognizes that all
schools are religious schools all
schools educate the entire child's Soul
heart intellect and body the question is
just how are they going to educate the
child liberalism does it by having
coming out ceremonies and Earth Day
ceremonies and transition ceremonies and
diversity trainings and all the rest of
it
Catholic schools do it through Catechism
classes
Jewish schools do it I don't really know
how Jewish schools do it I assume in
some kind of Jewish instruction
Muslim schools I don't really know how
they do it probably through some Muslim
instruction that's why they have
madrasas
but all schools do it and
the question is do you want your kid
educated in the leftist religion or in
the normal religion the true religion
there are going to be some religious
conservatives who are worried about this
it's not just going to be the
secularists and the libs World some
religious conservatives are going to be
where they're going to say we don't want
the state involved in our religious
education because then this the state is
going to exert influence so better to
say no to the state funding and keep our
own religious schools
where we can totally control it rather
than get the state involved at all
I see that worry but the greater threat
lies in not wielding the political power
look at the libs do you think that
having State support has undermined the
libs religious convictions no it's only
Amplified the libs religious convictions
and all the rights and all the rituals
and all the mantras and all the rest of
it
no the greater risk lies in not wielding
that power
because the state is going to be
animated by some kind of religion so I'd
rather it be ours than theirs
now the rest of the show is going to
continue right now you do not want to
miss it become a member use code Knowles
Canada wlas at checkout for two months
free on all annual plans
[Music]